thank you can you hear me I'm so pleased
to see so many of my like over goal
colleagues here I just want to thank you
for making me look so good I really
think of myself as more of an icon for
this collaboration and this nobel prize
is really something that i accept as a
representative of you who have made this
great success in the end i would like to
highlight the fact that the where we are
and where we are going in gravitational
wave astronomy and physics has relied on
three different efforts each of which
was roughly a half a century long in
order to get where we are and where
we're going
the first was discussed in considerable
detail by Ray Weiss and Barry bearish
the experimental effort and a little bit
along with that the data analysis effort
I want to talk about the theoretical
effort on understanding sources of
gravitational waves the waveforms that
are produced the shapes of the waves
produced by the these sources and the
information that is carried by those
waveforms then I want to talk briefly
very briefly about a third effort this
has lasted for about a half a century I
combined theoretical and experimental
effort on what is called quantum non
demolition that's a buzzword but I'll
explain what that buzzword means then I
will move into the future focusing on
what we where we might be in the 2030s
the four different frequency bands that
Barry barish introduced you to and then
beyond the twenty thirty so this is
where I'm going in this talk
let me just look at yeah okay just
looking at the time here okay
so so I want to begin however with some
personal remarks I was a graduate
student at Princeton in the period 1962
to 1965 my thesis advisor was John
Archibald wheeler a fabulous man who had
what seemed at the time wild ideas most
of which have come to be out too
to be true he was focusing and he taught
me about neutron stars and black holes
but I also as a hanger-on on the fringes
of Bob Nikki's experimental gravity
research group of which Ray Weiss at the
time was a member a doesn't remember me
in graduate school but I remember him
because he was a real intellectual giant
in Bob Nikki's group and I was sort of
sitting back there as a mousy theorist
trying to understand the experimental
side of this subject but I'm so glad I
did because I learned enough to in the
end be able to collaborate with ray
Weiss Ron dreamer very bearish right
I was also much influenced by Joseph
Weber whom Ray talked about Joe I met
and spent a lot of time with in the
French Alps at a summer school lasers in
laser their shaman II we went hiking in
the Alps and he told me all about his
plans and the experimental work that he
was already getting going on
gravitational wave detection and so it
was quite natural that when I went to
Caltech in 1966 as a professor a young
professor that I would build a theory
group that worked in black holes neutron
stars and the theory of gravitational
waves by 1972 together with colleagues
and students I'd begun to develop some
amount of vision for the science that
might be done with gravitational waves
the information that might be extracted
from gravitational waves and the key
idea is this in a general form that
there are only two kinds of waves that
can propagate across the universe
bringing us information about what's
very far away electromagnetic waves and
gravitational waves and that's it
according to the laws of physics and
there's an enormous difference between
the two types of waves electromagnetic
waves or oscillations of the
electromagnetic field that propagate
through space as time passes by contrast
gravitational waves are actually
oscillations of the fabric or shape of
space and time extremely different kinds
of phenomena electromagnetic waves are
generally in a stir
physics incoherent superpositions of
emission from individual particles and
atoms and molecules whereas the
gravitational waves are produced by
their coherent bulk motion of large
amounts of mass or energy
electromagnetic waves are all too easily
absorbed and scattered as they travel
through the universe so we only see a
small portion of the universe because
there's so much obscuration by gas and
dust
whereas gravitational waves are never
significantly absorbed or scattered even
if they're emitted near the Big Bang
with those differences it became very
quite clear and I think it was clear to
my theorist colleagues and students by
1972 many sources of gravitational waves
will never be seen electromagnetically
and the colliding black holes that we
have seen thus far there's been no
electromagnetic signal that surprises
then are likely and that there is a
potential to revolutionize our
understanding of the universe using this
radically different kind of waves so
that was what we had in mind already by
the early 1970s and that was the same
time 1972 Israeli Weiss having gone from
Princeton back to MIT as a young
professor he wrote a classic paper in
which he described the design for a in
her interferometric gravitational wave
detector and he identified all the major
noise sources these kinds of detectors
might have to deal with and how you
would deal with each of them and what
kinds of sensitivity you could get as a
result and he concluded that there was a
real chance to be able to build
detectors that could reach the
sensitivities that were required by the
sources that my colleagues and I were
thinking about now I looked at Ray's
ideas and I stated in a textbook a
classic textbook that I wrote was John
Wheeler my thesis advisor in Charles
sir that these are not very promising he
was telling us that you should build a
detector that measures the motions of
masses with ten to the minus twelve one
trillionth of the amplitude of motion
compared to the wavelength of the light
you're using you move measure a detector
that moves by an amount that is one one
thousandth the diameter the nucleus of
an atom and an atom nucleus is a hundred
thousand times smaller than an atom I
mean it just was crazy and then I
studied his paper which he didn't
publish in the regular literature he put
in an internal report at MIT because his
attitude was you don't publish something
like this until you've detected
gravitational waves but I he
disseminated it's quite widely among his
colleagues I read it and I began to
think well maybe this will work I had
this long night long all night
discussion with him in Washington DC
that he referred to
I had discussions with Vladimir
Brzezinski in Moscow and later with
Ronald Reaver whom we brought to Caltech
to start the Caltech effort I became
convinced and it seemed to me that
because the potential of this for human
future understanding the universe is so
great that I should do everything that I
could as a theorist
to help my experimental colleagues
succeed and so here I am I and my
students in the end draw to probably 70%
of our effort research effort from then
on July go let me now talk about sources
of gravitational waves 1978 we had a
workshop on sources of gravitational
waves gathered together essentially all
of the theorists and experimentalists
not here because he hasn't joined into
this field yet although he did play a
crucial role and get helping us get
Caltech into the field behind the scenes
on a committee that
commanded that we move forward in the
field and at that workshop at the end
there was a discussion of strengths of
sources and this comes from the paper
describing the workshop super novae
where an upper limit was here that's ten
to the minus twenty-one this is
frequency this is the strain that we've
been talking about compact binary
mergers that's black hole binary to
black holes two neutron stars a black
hole neutron star estimated to be in
this region and so it seemed clear to us
that the taught goal had to be to reach
a sensitivity of strain sensitivity of
ten to the minus twenty one and so we
even had t-shirts made up that said ten
to the minus twenty one or bust
there is the signal it came in the first
thing that was seen one times ten to the
minus twenty one that's obviously
largely luck that we were right on the
money but that was our gold beginning in
nineteen seventy eight and that's where
the first thing that came in 1983 when
we were planning legal it seemed pretty
clear to me the likely first detection
was binary black holes and this is
basically what I argued from then on
though I think most of the community was
expecting it to be two neutron stars but
it seemed to me already then that the
following would outweigh the neutron
stars were versa for the black holes in
favor of new truck black holes instead
of neutron stars the distance to which
you could see a signal for two objects
going around each other they're
approximately proportional to the masses
of the objects we were thinking of the
time the black holes we would be dealing
with for maybe ten times heavier than
neutron stars so you would see a volume
of the universe there would be a
thousand times greater than four neutron
stars and that seemed to me that would
outweigh the lower absolute numbers of
black holes there are in the universe
compared to neutron stars and that's how
it did turn out to be but we were very
uncertain as to how strong these waves
were but we knew it was somewhere in the
vicinity of that ten to the minus twenty
one numerical simulations
we're going to be needed it seemed very
clear to me in that era in order to be
able to extract the information from the
colliding black holes that they carry
because we could not with pencil and
paper and analytical techniques we could
not solve Einstein's equations to
compute the shapes of the gravitational
waves coming from colliding black holes
so we had to do it by numerical
relativity so let me go back a brief
history of numerical simulations this
begins in the 1950s motivated by Johnny
wheeler my thesis advisor who told us
already in the 1950s that we should try
to study the veritable storms in the
fabric of space and time that occur when
space and time the geometry of space and
time are highly excited in a nonlinear
fashion and rapidly changing and we had
and he said you go out and study this
thing that I called geometric dynamics
we tried we fell flat on our faces we
didn't have the tools to do it but he
recognized and they his students around
him recognized that in order to really
sort do this you had to do it
numerically so you'd be had to begin to
build the tools of solving Einstein's
equations and numerically on a computer
or computer simulations so the
foundations were laid in the ferret
period from 58 to 64 by Charles Messner
Richard link whist who are associated
with Johnny wheeler
Susan Hahn who was a computer scientist
at IBM who teamed up with Richard
Lindquist to start this out this is the
best photograph I can find a linguist in
that era it was not however until 1978
the first successful collision a
simulation was done of head-on
collisions of two black holes by Larry
Smarr and Kenneth F Lee building on
foundations laid by Bryce to it and
earlier foundations of Misner HANA
Lindquist and there are a number of
other contributors in this period I'm
highlighting the people who were really
the Giants in this early era
so here 58 to 78 this is 20 years
already
struggling to get this started next was
the problem of doing two black holes
that circle around each other and spiral
together collide and merge and the
community began to work on that and it
became a very concerted effort by 1983
when we were and I started when we were
co-founding LIGO and we were telling our
colleagues doing these simulations we
really need these simulations in order
to extract information from the way so
you'll see by the 1990s there was a
something called the binary black hole
grand challenge alliance led by Richard
Matzner at the University of Texas all
of the world's experts in this getting
together and working in a concerted sort
of a way and I became a little concerned
that was going more slowly than it
should be so I made a bet I like to make
bets and I made a bet that I hereby
wager that LIGO will discover convincing
gravitational waves from black hole
coalescence or merger before the
numerical relativity community has a
code capable of computing waveforms I
wanted to lose this bet and the worst
possible way I wanted to lose this bet
by the early two thousands I paint came
alarmed the progress really was slower
than the experimental progress why was
it slow it's been really hard you're
trying to simulate not two things that
collide in space and time you're
simulating things they're made out of
warp space in time that are colliding so
you don't have an arena in which this is
going on you're simulating the arena
itself a warped arena and it says this
is going on and so by the early
two-thousands I became alarmed and so I
started in collaboration with Salter
Kolski at Cornell what we call the sxs
collaboration to work in this field Saul
had been working on this already for a
few years and 2004 the first successful
simulations were done my friends
Pretorius a postdoc in our group joan
central emanuelle at compa nelly and
their research groups by 2014 the
simulations were mature
enough for the first leg of observations
and I conceded the bet with great
happiness and when the Smurfs signal
came in in September 14 2015 the
numerical relativity gravitational wave
form is the red here the observed wave
form is the gray and that matched
beautifully and by comparing those waves
the theoretical and the observational
with each other we inferred the
properties of the black holes and the
distance to the sources this is a you
can then go back knowing from the
observations of the comparison of the
theoretical waveforms of the
observational waveforms you can go back
and look at the simulations and see what
was happening during those simulations
and this is a simulation of the
colliding black holes has seen from
outside our universe looking in on the
warped shape of space and time around
the black hole the red is the slowing of
time the arrows are the dragging of
space and emotion is a gigantic splash
in the shape of space and the slowing of
time and then an oscillation the
gravitational waves go propagating out
you can also compute what it would have
looked like to your eyes if you had seen
the two black holes go around each other
collide and merge creating what's called
gravitational lensing distorting the
star field that's behind the two black
holes and this is a movie that was
played extensively at the time of the
first discovery that came again from
this xs/s collaboration it was essential
that we not only had numerical
relativity simulations but for the
earlier parts of the waveforms they were
computed by a different technique called
post-newtonian expansion which I won't
go into detail but that was another
40-year effort led primarily by Luc
Blanchette tiro no more and then the
matching the two together by a different
technique
led by tiro de Moura and Alessandra
Bruin
so that was the way we had the wave
farms that we needed quantum not in
demolition I just want to mention very
briefly because I'm also running out of
time the challenge is to monitor the
motions of 40 kilogram mirrors to a
precision that is 10 to the minus 17
centimeters which turns out to be
approximately the half width of the
quantum mechanical wave function of the
center of mass degrees of freedom of
these mirrors so the challenge in
advanced LIGO
is to deal with quantum flexural and
fluctuations of the motions of the
mirrors themselves to circumvent the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle and
this means that for the first time in
advanced LIGO humans see human sized
objects behave quantum mechanically and
that has required developing a field of
technology called quantum don demolition
technology to deal with this this is a
branch of modern quantum information
science it was Vladimir Brzezinski in
1968 that told us we need to do to do
this no matter what kind of gravity wave
detectors rebuilt I didn't understand
what he was saying for 10 years and then
I finally understood and then I had my
research group work as closely as
possible with his research group to work
out the techniques for this i've running
out of time I'm going to skip over my
discussion of the techniques for this
except to say that the key idea which
comes primarily from carlton caves and
from bill unruhe
is that use take the vacuum of quantum
electrodynamics the vacuum fluctuations
of light and you modify that vacuum by
what is called squeezing and you inject
the squeezed vacuum into the back end of
the interferometer it's it sounds just
crazy but this turns out to be
absolutely crucial for the future of
this field when we go beyond advanced
LIGO I want to wind up by briefly
talking about gravitational wave
astronomy in the 2030s there are four
different frequency bands that Barry
barish talked about
the low frequency band minutes to hours
to be studied by Lisa these four three
spacecraft attract each other with laser
beams it's a ISA mission we hope that it
launches by about twenty thirty and Lisa
is capable of monitoring the
gravitational waves from giant black
holes millions of Suns that spiral
around each other collide and merge with
sigla noise ratios of ten thousand or
more and thereby capable of studying
geometry dynamics with unbelievably high
precision pulsar timing arrays a
gravitational wave sweeps across the
earth and it speeds up or slows down all
the clocks on the earth and so naturally
if you time the radio time pulsars at
different locations on the sky they will
all slow down and speed up our pair to
slow down to speed up in synchrony
because it's the clocks on the earth
that are being screwed up and that
technique will look at great supergiant
black holes
billions of Suns in mass so we cover the
whole range some solar mass scale of
black holes and millions of solar masses
to billions of solar masses and a small
black hole going orbiting around a large
black hole generates gravitational waves
that carry a full map of the large black
hole that is being explored by this
small black hole as the small black hole
goes around it in orbits and here's the
small black hole going around the large
black hole the orbit is wildly crazy
because of the dragging of space into
motion by the big black hole as well as
other relativistic effects and it's
samples essentially the entire space
around the big black hole and gives us
then the information to do exquisitely
accurate mapping of the geometry of
space and time around big black holes
what are the central bodies not a black
hole for example the naked singularity
the orbits will be wildly different and
the maps will be wildly different so we
have the capabilities search for
unexpected kinds of massive central
bodies I want to wind up by saying that
we have a potential to study the
moments of the universe by the 2030s
when the universe was at an age of 10 to
the minus 12 seconds there is predicted
to have been a electroweak phase
transmission where the electromagnetic
force and the weak force come apart and
gain their own individual identities the
birth of the laws of electromagnetism
and this may have occurred in what's
called a first order phase transition
inside bubbles the bubbles of the new
phase where electromagnetic force does
exist in the bulk of the old face where
it doesn't exist collide produce
gravitational waves which today have
been redshift into Lisa's frequency band
and like who could see similar phase
transitions that would have occurred
when the universe was 10 to the minus 22
seconds so we have no idea what was
going on in the universe at age twenty
ten to minus twenty two seconds
primordial gravitational waves coming
off of the Big Bang itself are predicted
to have been amplified whatever came off
the Big Bang amplified by inflation in
the first ten to the minus thirty three
seconds of the universe theoretical
prediction that is pretty from strongly
believed by the theoretical physicists
and what is speculated to come off the
Big Bang is vacuum fluctuations the
minimum amount of fluctuation of the
gravitational field that are possible
they would get amplified to make a
rather rich spectrum of real
gravitational waves that would propagate
out interact with a hot plasma and the
universe was 383 380,000 years old and
put out polarization on the Cosmic
Microwave Background produced by the hot
electrons at that age which would be
seen today and so they challenged the
people who work with the Cosmic
Microwave Background is to measure
definitively that polarization thereby
infer the gravitational waves that came
off the Big Bang can volved with the
effects of inflation so the spectrum
that would be seen is a convolution a
combination of the effects of inflation
and what came off the Big Bang we also
have the
by 2050 to fly a successor to the Lisa
mission which be capable of seeing these
gravitational waves from the earliest
moments of the universe independently at
periods of a few seconds so imagine if
you had the gravitational wave with
periods of a few seconds you have their
primordial gravitational waves with
periods of hundred million years seen by
polarization on this guy polarization
pattern on the sky both of them are
produced by whatever came off the Big
Bang can volved with the effects of
inflation and I envisioned that by the
2050s those will not agree there will
not be an agreement between what's
coming off at periods of one of a few
seconds at periods of 100 million years
and there will be a huge mystery what
really came off the Big Bang why was it
not vacuum fluctuation so that's my
dream of the future and that at that
point those observations may really feed
into understanding the laws of quantum
gravity that govern the birth of the
universe so let me just conclude by
saying it was 400 years ago that Galileo
created modern electromagnetic astronomy
by turning a small optic telescope on
the sky and discovering the moons of
Jupiter it was two years ago that this
wonderful Lyell Virgo collaboration
turned on the advance detectors the
advanced LIGO detectors and saw the
gravitational waves from collisions of
two black holes in those four hundred
years since Galileo we have learned so
much about the universe with optical
Astronomy our understanding of the
universe is so different today than it
was 400 years ago thanks to optical
Astronomy what might be the future 400
years from now when we have 400 years in
our pockets of gravitational astronomy
together with electromagnetic astronomy
I think the future is really very very
exciting thank you
[Applause]
so I I would not cost professor vice and
mr. Barrett so if you go over to the bar
in the front of the stage so you you can
advance selected
[Applause]
okay